now over at the 2022 naacp image awards
meghan markle and prince harry began
their acceptance speech for the
president's award by paying tribute to
the people of ukraine we are so deeply
humbled to be here in the company of so
many illustrious awardees before i begin
we would like to acknowledge the people
of ukraine who urgently need our
continued support as a global community
harry also thanked the black community
for welcoming him during their joint
speech marking their first award show
appearance this year i also echo the
immense gratitude for tonight
both for this award and to this
community for welcoming me with uh so
warmly
i think it's safe to say that i come
from a very different background than my
incredible wife
yet our lives were brought together for
a reason and i couldn't be prouder that
we're doing this work together why do
you think the duke and duchess of sussex
are deserving of this incredible award
they're pioneers and
they fight for what's right um
they've shown the world a side
of the world that many people didn't
know before and i think people relate to
them on a great way other big names
joining the winners circle included issa
rae for outstanding comedy series and
will smith for outstanding actor i'm
just so honored to receive this and i
know i forgot hella people that's okay
your time's up
for me to have this opportunity to tell
this story and deliver this to you and
to the world is one of the greatest
honors of of my entire career and angela
bassett accepted the award for
outstanding actress in a drama series
but accidentally blanked on her son's
name penultimately my family courtney
slater and bronwyn and piper the dog for
being the ultimate support of my life i
was doing pretty good and thought really
well on myself and then i forgot my
slice my chilled child's name